you
okay just friend 90m yeah let's try you
for feel so much more relaxed playing
these blitz games it's a nice change up
from the craziness all right a Rui ad3
Rui
alright let's strike with a for right
now let's see what you do
there's no bishop here right away and if
you do that
okay let's stop Knight a5 he might be
overextended this stuff it's castle ooh
it's almost a bad Mouse lip okay
they're going straight in for that
prepared to defend let's see don't know
if it's correct but you know let's take
put pressure on this guy push turnip in
they might be able to do that though I
may have this move may I think I will
see for maybe here
strike at the light square bishop I'm
not quite sure
let me first rule out Bishop g5 okay
they've weakened their dark squares so
let's go hmm let's go here Bishop back
Bishop g5 they've weakened their dark
squares I'd like to have a dark square
Bishop exchange could maybe hit the
Queen further if she moves with Knight
c5 she currently has a job this is
uncomfortable spot for the Queen okay
let's try that have five right away the
Knights and a pin I actually don't have
to react to that move some pawn takes
Knight pawn takes and I'm attacking the
pin piece this is a scary diagonal you
could dislodge the knight but there's
some concern with the King position they
must feel a little bit uncomfortable
here with the configuration of their
Queen and Bishop so this is a still this
is still something that I want this
exchanged our scribe bishops wasn't
expecting that I must be better here
I got a completely open D file now
attempt I move with Knight c5 I think I
should do that right now
this is almost
working no it's not huh well maybe
something straightforward like doubling
on the e-file I think this is somewhat
helping black because there are then out
of the pin let's just look to double
okay and let's continue
double up I want them to invite me
forward even on the clock hmm so I have
this as a jumping point on e6 mm-hmm
also a tempo move with Knight g3 let's
look more forward first yeah I'm gonna
do this yeah I'm entering I'm gonna get
a pig on the seventh and my queen on h6
let's take here the King has to take
mmm-hmm the rook could blow
I get my I get my rook ACK my queen to
h6 oh now they could block with their
they could take with their queen all
right change of plans
let's put them in a pin what I guess
they miss oh my goodness I just fell for
me oh my god
g2 I'm glad it wasn't h2o Queen takes g2
I didn't even realize that I made one
threat oh my goodness look at how quick
I'm like oh that's a blunder man I could
just take the rook they could take your
king buddy oh man Queen takes G - ah man
that was bad that was really bad all
right let's see where I went wrong right
here okay let's go back in I really like
my position until I fell for me let's
request a computer evaluation
ah what a what a cruel end I want a
cruel end let's read this quote while
we're waiting chess
it's like alcohol it's a drug I have to
control it or could overwhelming see I
knew I had something good going on until
that point checkmate is now unavoidable
rook takes beasts rook takes b8 you
don't say you don't say okay all right
well aside from that missed million won
hmm let's see
yeah wins d4 it's not really a big fan
of d4
it's to play the more reserved d3
well yeah one way to reason that is play
d6 you don't give me something to bite
at ID on e5 and then you could still try
for this idea of hunting down my pawn if
I'm trying to defend it with Knight c4
there is Bishop here to eliminate that
guy you would have to invest the bishop
pair just to grab that pawn then he
could turn out to be quite powerful
piece I don't know
in any case d6 is the suggestion d6
night here Bishop their Bishop here I
feel like I do want to prep that first I
don't know weird move now h3 right there
oh okay this is an interesting maneuver
maybe if I'm taking then there's this a
knight at this nice jumping point on
each on d4 maybe hmm
okay so d6 instead of that d5 was played
and this is where I now have a pretty
significant advantage approaching upon
ya there I wanted the dark square Bishop
saddle right around this point takes
yeah there's got to be something good
here I thought about Queen f4 but what
is what was the point of that after they
like move their king oh I
doing this stuff here takes takes and
then takes yeah okay
Queen f4 is actually throwing a punch I
was just I saw that this was a move
because the Knights pinned but I wasn't
seeing that oh I'm ready to take and
then take on c7 I should have something
here just um on these on these ideas
here the rook already ideally placed on
an open file a little bit of
backwardness here with the Queen side
pieces the Queen and Bishop nuts so well
coordinated nice bishop here these guys
might you might classify them as a bit
overextended I'm ready to remove their
dark square Bishop which is a very
important defender for their King and
they have a more vulnerable King because
of the F pawn pushing yikes so it is +6
here oh I should take here first and
then enter +6 what did I do here how
could I have adjusted things maintain
this tension let's go back I should take
and then here and if this then I go here
hmm suppose they crawl up into a ball
and I take and then rook here or Queen
here oh that's painful huh I can see how
it's all playing out now oh yeah oh oh
that's a cool move Knight h5 mate next
Queen here or here if Queen takes f6 is
available you do that and that's me
that's a cool move once you have them I
mean it's already winning of course from
that point but Knight h5 is nice that
sharp lateral influence okay but how did
it play out let's see that in super
slo-mo
oh here's you know what I like this
feature I wasn't aware of this feature
here but you could um you could auto
play this in real time how the game
played how so you could see how fast I
was let's see this is how it played out
in real time are they gonna go yep look
at how quick I was take through how
quick they were to me oh don't you dare
relive that making one again but yeah
that's a pretty neat feature I was not
always aware of this you could see the
the amount of time that was played out
or you could just rewatch a game you
know with this auto play real time nice
this is a really nice feature okay let's
now look at that main one again ever
you